please welcome zach galifianakis
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was incredibly impressive what a
fall yeah i got confused how they enter
i want to see that in slow motion again
see if they can find that that was
incredible are you okay yeah right yeah
i'm a little winded yeah you landed in
this oh we got it let's take a look i
just want to see uh
amazing
[Music]
wow
incredible
look like a ninja
you seem really shook up by that yeah
i'm gonna be okay
i'm not sure you are okay there's blood
coming out your ears again no again
[Laughter]
let's stop at someone first of all so
much to talk about and we'll get to uh
probably the most anticipated film of
the year hangover part two people very
excited to see this movie but let's just
talk first of all about i say your name
and i've known you for a long time we
used to have you on the old late night
show years ago back in the late 40s
early 50s
and you have a very interesting as show
business names go most people change
their name to like joe
jet
or blue blaze something easy
no one's done that i'm sorry
but you are zach galifianakis and i've
noticed people have a lot of trouble
pronouncing your name when they when
you're on their show
uh yeah i i i
i'm still i still really don't know how
to say it
would you have trouble with it i have
trouble with it but uh you know
it's it's a tough name to to uh to get
out and i understand that people mess it
up yeah
the
the one the most butchered
time it ever happened was you know
you'll
if you fly somewhere and you're in show
business
um
hey i'm in show business too
anyway you know what yeah oh boy
yeah
uh what's it like fellas
so that you fly places and what happens
you fly on airplanes um airplanes uh but
the uh
sometimes there's somebody over there be
there to pick you up if you're like
going to uh like a comedy festival
they'll hire someone to pick you up and
hold you know your name your name
and a few years ago i was
i was i've landed and i was calling like
i couldn't see my name uh
and i'm calling the person that was
running the comedy festival and i was
like you know i'm i can't find the
person holding my
oh i see it
and it just said it was a guy standing
there with his mouth open like this
and it just said gaspa fanasky
yeah i found it
mister the gas with financial
pedestrians we actually noticed that uh
hosts of tv shows who were supposed to
know better have a lot of trouble we put
together a little uh montage here take a
look
let's talk about zac galifianiakis
zach oh my god that's zac
uh zach galifiana
that guy's name is zach gina finocchis
zach gianfopolis
rivas is just screwing with you no
respect
you